hello ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to this talk on high grad pi
which is a python library implementing
the hierarchical incremental gradient
descent algorithm
let me start by first introducing myself
i'm vihan singh i'm based out of india
and i recently completed my bachelor's
in mathematics in computer science
i run a quantitative trading firm called
black rose technologies
where we basically use machine learning
statistics in computer science
to try and make money out of the stock
market
now the core content of this
presentation and the algorithm that's
implemented in the python library
is not something i came up with it was
created by mr sue and mr zoo
i'll not take the risk of pronouncing
their full names
to avoid the embarrassment of butchering
the pronunciations
about two years ago in 2018 when there
were researchers at the university of
pennsylvania
they conduct they published a very uh
heavy uh title paper called uncertainty
quantification for online learning and
stochastic approximation via
hierarchical incremental gradient
descent
right so in that paper um they discussed
the high grad algorithm
um and that and they also implemented it
in a
r library of the same name which is
basically what inspired the high grad
pie library
and which is what i'm here to present so
let me first set the stage
um by going over how
like machine learning basically works
right um
step one is you choose a model the model
could be
something simple like linear regression
where you're trying to find the line
that best fits
uh some data points it could be
say the support vector machine where
you're trying to find the hyper plane
that best separates um
two different uh set of points
and it could be a neural network which
you know is basically approximating a
very complex non-linear function
with the various layers and the nodes
regardless of what model you pick
you basically have to train the model
right
and training the model is essentially an
optimization problem
you have some variables or for the model
you you might call them
model parameters those parameters have
some constraints
basically they have some permissible
values
that they can take on and then you have
an objective function
the objective function is basically what
um tells you the performance of your
model if you're trying to maximize the
objective function
uh it probably represents something like
accuracy if you're trying to minimize it
in which case it's also called the loss
function the error function the cost
function
it is basically a measure for the
difference between the predictions that
your model is making and the actual
values
that they represent um
now to train um a model the classic
approach
is an algorithm called the gradient
descent or the batch gradient descent
what it basically does is um it passes
all the data points
through the model and uh which spits out
the predictions
uh for those data points now
it computes the difference or the error
for
um all the different data points and
what they
what the actual value should be so the
error
in your predictions and then it computes
the gradient
the gradient is basically the direction
uh in which
you know if the model parameters were to
be moved in that direction would
minimize
the error for that data point and it
takes
an average of these different gradients
and multiplies it by the learning rate
which is a coefficient
that you know um is supposed to
say dampen or amplify the step that um
the the model parameters are taking in
the direction of the gradient
set the learning rate too small and the
model will take a very long time to
converge
set it too high and it'll just bounce
all over the place and have a very hard
time converging
so this is sort of like a problem where
you have to find the goldilocks
learning rate for your model train
right and then you're supposed to repeat
this process of
you know the model making predictions
compute the error
find the gradient take the average
multiplied by the learning rate and take
a step in that direction
and you keep doing this over and over
again till the model converges
converging being that there's no
significant improvement
in the performance anymore so
that's what the gradient descent
algorithm does now how does this
algorithm fare against modern machine
learning problems well as it turns out
it doesn't fare too well
first gradient descent is an offline
algorithm
which means that it requires the entire
data set to be available on hand
at once for it to do the training
process
however most uh machine learning
problems uh today
often have streaming data sets which
means um
that the data is coming in on the fly in
real time and then you have to process
it train the model and then move to the
next data point
um so that's the first uh shortcoming of
the gradient descent algorithm the
second
is you know modern machine learning
problems have very large data sets right
there were a lot of
uh data points in them which makes
gradient descent a very computationally
expensive algorithm to implement
because there's just so many points that
you have to compare the gradients for
and then
um it's just you know pain in the ass
and many times
uh the entire data set doesn't even fit
in memory
uh of the machine that you're working on
so
you know radian descent is not the
optimal answer
hence we have the stochastic gradient
descent also known as the incremental
gradient descent
how does this differ from the gradient
descent which is also called the batch
gradient descent
is that instead of using the entire data
set when it's computing the gradient
and taking the gradient step it uses
either one
randomly selected or some randomly
sampled uh data points
from the data set that you're working
with so what this basically does is
reduces the computational overhead that
you have
number one and number two it can then
process um you know the
data in an online fashion or in a
streaming fashion that
the data can come in it doesn't require
the entire data set at once
it can have just some point or some
points from the data set and it can
compute the gradient take a step
right so hence it fails much better
against modern machine learning problems
because one it's an
online algorithm which is basically the
fancy way of saying that
it can handle uh streaming data that the
data comes in it computes
uh the gradient does the gradient
descent step and then
throws the data it doesn't need to keep
it um and it can work for very large
data sets also because you're only
computing the gradients for some small
subset
of all the data points so it's uh far
more efficient compared to the batch
gradient descent
and the stochastic gradient descent is
basically like the de facto standard for
training machine learning models today
and once you've trained the machine
learning models
you make predictions using those models
and herein lies the rub because
when you train something using the
stochastic gradient descent algorithm
and as the name would suggest stochastic
gradient descent there's some element of
randomness involved
right and what that basically does is
um it yields a degree of uh
noise in the predictions so if you were
to take the same data set and run the
stochastic gradient descent multiple
times
it could be that in different iterations
you have very different answers to the
same
data inputs and the authors
of the paper actually conducted
an experiment or conducted a test to you
know test this more formally
what they did was they got a data set
from
the oci machine learning repository the
name of the data set was
the adult data set but it's not nearly
as raunchy as it sounds it's just
um a hundred plus features that you try
to
use for a binary classification problem
we're trying to
predict whether uh the person's annual
income is more than or less than fifty
thousand dollars
so they uh i think they did like 500
different
uh iterations of the stochastic gradient
descent for that data set
and what they found was that um there's
a very high degree of variability
uh in the answers across the iterations
and
in some degree in some in some
iterations the
variability could be as high as 50 which
means
that your model predictions are no
better than just a coin flip
right and given that machine learning is
becoming more and more a part of
you know mainstream applications this
kind of
uncertainty in predictions cannot go
under just
and that is basically what they try to
do with the high grad algorithm
so it's sort of like a different
way of looking at things it's um sort of
a different paradigm
um so so far the
way we're all familiar with these
machine learning problems you have some
you know ground troop the actual value
of some data point
say in this case it's 6.9 your model
makes a prediction
uh for that value say the the model
predicts 6.4
right and this is usually what we'll be
working with
the actual value and which is y and the
y hat which is your mod what your model
predicts
what the high grad algorithm does and
what the
authors propose and others have also
proposed in other ways is
um the idea of attaching confidence
intervals
to these predictions um so instead of
just saying
that the model thinks the answer is 6.4
the model will say that i think the
answers between 5.5 and 7.3
with a 95 confidence um
and this you know is that that
confidence interval and the length of
that interval is
a quantification of the uncertainty of
that model's prediction
if it's a very wide interval you know
that this model isn't very confident
about what it's predicting
if it's a fairly tight interval you can
be more confident about
uh the predictions of the model now
given we're working with
confidence intervals one term that you
should be familiar with
is coverage probability now it's a very
fancy
term to um denote something fairly
simple
when you're working with confidence
intervals you're going to specify an
interval for the values
and whether that value whether the true
value
falls within that confidence interval or
not
is basically you know the
it's basically the success of failure of
that confidence interval the coverage
probability
is essentially the probability that this
happens so over multiple iterations
it tells you whether um the
true value falls within the confidence
interval that you've proposed
so in this image you can see so there's
like a lot of uh data points on the
screen
and the ones in yellow so there's like
the
the point itself you could think of as
the prediction and then the
uh the wicks that you see uh above and
below the point
are like the confidence interval and
basically all of these predictions are
for
the zero uh mean uh
of data right they're just all trying to
predict zero
effectively so all the ones that are
yellow um
essentially do include zero in it in the
confidence interval
so they're all um like uh good
so they're correct however the blue
points do not include the zero so
those all of those confidence intervals
are wrong and
say if you're correct 95 of the time the
coverage probability would be 95
or 0.95 so that's a term to be familiar
with
um given we're working with confidence
intervals now and is basically a test
for
how well those confidence intervals work
and is one of the metrics that the
authors even use in the paper to judge
how well the high grad algorithm and
certain configurations of it do
the other one that they use is called
informativeness um
which is basically a measure of the
length of the confidence interval for
example
in this case 5.5 and 7.3 so uh that's
like 1.8
is the length of this interval um and if
the interval interval's wider
the prediction doesn't really have much
information in it right so if you know
the
answers are going to vary the answer is
usually going to vary between 0
and 10 and the model spits out a
confidence interval that that
says you know i think with 95 percent
confidence that the answer is going to
be between 0 and 10 it doesn't really
tell you much
so that's basic however if it says the
answer is probably going to be between
5.5 and 5.9 then this is like a far more
informative prediction
than just saying it's between 0 and 10.
so
another metric to keep in mind uh that
the author is also used in the paper
so now we get to the actual algorithm
and the
associated python library
the algorithm called hierarchical
incremental gradient descent
it has this very fancy logo um which i
i'm pretty sure is unofficial
it was on the github page of the
r library that they have for the high
grad algorithm and i really liked it so
i
kept it and i put it on my github page
also for the high grad pi
so and it actually very well represents
what
happens in the algorithm basically the
prongs of the trident
represent um the different threads that
the sgde splits into
so this is the high grad algorithm
itself
formerly like written down in pseudocode
i won't go into the math behind the
algorithm
as much simply because i feel the
authors can probably explain the math
much better than i can
so if you want to learn um what happens
under the hood
i would uh point you to the 50 page
research paper that they have on the
subject
and like the 100 plus slide presentation
that one of the authors has on the
subject
so that's where you should go if you
want to thoroughly understand what's
going on with the algorithm
my objective here is going to be uh
giving you
a more uh intuitive overview of what
happens
and then showcasing the library itself
so this is what um
happens uh in the high grad algorithm it
starts out
the same as any other stochastic
gradient descent so the hybrid basically
builds upon
so incremental gradient descent is
basically stochastic gradient descent
so that's the same as what we've already
discussed in your what you're familiar
with
the hierarchical part is where the
novelty lies
so it starts out the same as
the usual stochastic gradient descent
and
up to some you know uh number of
iterations
post which it splits into multiple
threads
right and the number of threads that
will split into is
a hyper parameter that you choose even
the number of steps it will
process as a single singular uh thread
before it
creates the first split is also a hyper
parameter
and um those i'll get to in a bit
so basically it starts out as the usual
stochastic gradient descent and then
splits into
two or more threads right and now so
this is like say level
uh so we were at level one now there's
level two
of this um of the algorithms training
now these individual threads can further
split into more threads
um maybe they split into two three four
or more
and could be they both split into the
same number or different number of
threads further
and all of these are hyper parameters
that we set um
for the algorithm and now what happens
is so there are multiple levels and
so basically these are the hierarchy uh
across
um the training that's going on so
there's level one where you had just one
thread
then level two where it's split into two
or more and then when each of them
splits into furthermore
you know you have level three and four
and so on
so this is um
where things get found so what happens
instead of uh
taking like so how do the things change
first up how does the gradient step
change
so instead of the gradient step being
you know just one singular
um instance um it's now multiple threads
where each of them has some um you know
gradient step as per its own thread um
and we take the weighted average across
those uh
within the same thread so for each step
within the thread
and then we take the average across all
threads
right so i don't know if this uh diagram
is making sense to you or not
so if we just look at you know from left
to right
the first um the first piece so to speak
the second piece uh that is the one
above it and the third piece that's the
one above that
so these three threads um
so they're not really three threads it's
basically uh the same thread um
with three different pieces so we take
the weighted
average of the first piece the second
piece and the
third piece um the respective gradients
and
this weighted average is then averaged
across
all the different threads the four
threads that we have uh in front of us
um the four leaves so to speak
right so this is basically a tree and
those end points are the leaves
we take the average across those and
that is going to be the gradient step
so um much much more fancy
than the standard the vanilla stochastic
gradient descent
how the inference changes um which is
basically how does the model make a
prediction
instead of uh giving you its usual
prediction it will now
run a prediction through each one of the
threads and will take the average of all
them
and using those it will also
uh and again these are non-trivial
in the sense that it's not um you know
it's not like
just some basic computation it uh
includes like the correlations and the
covariances and the standard errors
and then creates like a confidence
interval um
for the prediction uh above and below
the estimate so there is
so each time when you ask the model for
a prediction
it not only gives you a prediction
itself it also attaches a confidence
interval to it
um yeah so
another thing to understand um
within the algorithm and this is like
the the two more uh
the two most important hyper parameters
um of
the high grad algorithm um
and the id the underlying ideas being
contrasting and sharing
um contrasting is the idea of
having many different threads in the
training
and in the model which all contrast
you know um the different values
right so each one of them will give you
a different prediction for the same date
uh
for the same uh data point and then
contrasting these uh you'll uh
you'll construct the confidence interval
sharing is the idea of sharing the
gradients across these different threads
and then computing the average to take a
step
uh with the gradient descent step so
contrasting requires more and more
threads
and so the two
hyper parameters here are how long do
you wait before you split
or you start splitting into threads and
how many threads just
does each uh branch split into so
the more contrasting you have the less
sharing there will be
because when you have like a lot of
threads um
and there's a lot of gradients so
there's not much weight
to each gradient however when you try to
increase sharing in which case you have
lower
um like lower and the lesser number of
threads and longer threads
you'll have lesser contrasting also so
this is
uh where you have to strike the balance
uh and we're back to that goldilocks uh
situation that we did with say the
learning rate
um or you could think of you know say
the bias variance tradeoff
so contrasting and sharing is another
one of those um
tug-of-war problems where you know
getting more of one means
less of the other so
yeah this is basically uh something to
be aware of
and i'll show you an example with the
data
uh that shadows that better demonstrates
this
visually um yeah so
that that that was basically the
overview of the algorithm itself
um and what does it effectively achieve
right
so as the pred as a practitioner what do
you care about
number one um it retains the online
nature of the vanilla stochastic radiant
descent
so that's a plus and the best part is
it's
at the same computational cost so even
though my explanation of it
or you know on an intuitive level it
might seem like
because there's a lot more going on this
is going to be computationally more
expensive
however it's not it's um it
the computational cost is the same as a
vanilla stochastic gradient descent so
essentially all this additional
information about the confidence
interval that you get
is for free right computationally
speaking
so and everyone likes free stuff right
so
that's a good thing uh number two
instead of just having the estimator
which was like
the which is like the prediction that
you would get out of the vanilla
stochastic gradient descent
you get the estimator plus you get a
confidence interval attached to that
estimate
so that's number two and number three is
that the estimator that you would get
is uh almost as accurate as just the
vanilla stochastic gradient descent
right so you aren't really losing out on
anything and you're getting
the confidence interval information and
also
as a bonus the high grad algorithm is
far easier to parallelize than the
vanilla stochastic gradient
centers so that's another plus
now getting to the library itself it's
um already uploaded to
uh pipey or pi pi depending on how you
pronounce it
so you can do a pip install high grad pi
and fetch it
so we're currently on version 0.17
the picture on screen is outdated
so you can easily install the library
and with the library itself the api i've
tried to keep it as
similar to cycle learn as possible
because um
if you have any experience or even if
you've done any basic course
on uh machine learning with python
you've
for sure been introduced to the
scikit-learn library
and um the scikit-learn api is like
the standard right that you create the
model
uh you do model dot fit and you do
modern dot predict to get the answer
so the high grad pi api works in the
exact same way
you import the model from the high grad
pile library
you create the model object you do model
fit
you do modern predict and you're done
so now going over the actual library
itself
when you're initializing an instance of
the model there's a lot
of hyper parameters that you can set
like with any other machine learning
model
i won't go over uh what all of these are
they're
fairly exhaustively explained in the
documentation
which you can go through um or you can
just uh
the dot string will tell you all of this
information too i don't think i have the
documentation up yet so just go through
the docs ring
um and it's not and also bear in mind
that high grad
is currently only implemented for linear
uh regression and logistic regression
which is basically what the high grad
library in the our library that the
authors had created
was implemented for so i've also uh only
implemented it for linear regression and
logistic regression
hopefully in the future we'll extend it
to more um
[Music]
through other machine learning
algorithms and machine learning models
and make it even more useful so
yeah so these are like the different um
hyper parameters that you can set
and once you have that you know in this
case i've just created a
dummy data set and you know split it
into chain and test data sets you fit
you predict you can use
uh you can score it also and it
automatically figures out you know
if it's a linear model it'll give you um
i think the root
i think it was the mean squared error
and if it's um
uh if it's a logistic model that'll give
you the accuracy and
when you make the predictions you'll get
your y hat and you'll get an upper and a
lower bound for the confidence interval
and basically that is as promised by the
hagrid algorithm
so this is what it will look like i've
just plotted it so in the white use the
lines that you see
um are the upper and lower bounds for
the confidence interval in this case i
think it's the 95
confidence interval you can change that
um as a
input parameter as a hyper parameter of
the model
and if you if you look at this
uh plot you'll see how many times
um so basically the coverage probability
of this is pretty
decent and many times the red dot
which is the actual value the true value
falls within the
confidence interval that the model has
predicted sometimes it doesn't but
that is to be expected so
yeah and in this uh
slide i basically uh have four different
plots
for uh the same data set uh but
different type of parameters for the
number of splits and the number of
threads
so the number of splits is how many
times the tree is going to split and the
number of threads is how many threads
each trees
each thread splits into so
uh two splits into two threads is
basically the splits will happen
twice so starting with the singular
thread they'll split into two threads
each and each of those two will
split into two threads each number when
i set the number of splits to three
the same thing will happen three times
so once pressed to two two splits to
four four split
uh two each to eight right and you can
see how the confidence interval and the
predictions
uh change for each and as you increase
the number of splits and the number of
threads
the confidence interval starts becoming
much tighter
which depending on what your uh doing
might be a good thing or might not be a
good thing so you have to compute the
coverage probability of this i think i
can turn that into a function also
and make things easier so yeah
i'll actually add that um adding uh
coverage probability
as a function that you can call
um yeah so that's about it
and one thing to bear in mind about the
number of threads
that you split into um
when you're first thinking about the
idea of first exploring this
and it did for me also um the idea of
splitting into a lot of threads
seems like a like an obvious thing to do
an obvious thing to do however that is
not
a very good idea because it just um
increases the bias that you have um
in your predictions and it doesn't
really yield very good numbers
um and in the paper also the the authors
have uh
gone over how you know in most cases
four like
four or less uh threads are
going to be sufficient the number of
tests that you split into
keeping it four or less than that is
probably sufficient and four i think was
like the optimal number
but um just to be
sure you know i'd suggest you go through
the paper
so yeah that is it um
[Music]
you can reach me on any of these via
email twitter
or you can go to my github where the
libraries host
the library is hosted and
yeah i hope you enjoyed this and i'll
see you guys in the live q a session
bye